la parole est à madame dominique nachury
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
il y a peu été remis le rapport portant
propositions pour une stratégie
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur
qui affirme beaucoup d'ambitions pour
l'enseignement supérieur veut répondre
aux aspirations de la jeunesse et trace
des pistes d'avenir
il y a quelques semaines ou quelques
jours avait lieu la rentrée
universitaire rentrée parfois différé
comme à toulouse pour 12 cents étudiants
rentrés avec 65 mille étudiants de plus
qu'en 2014 soit l'équivalent de trois
universités rentrée après des tests
d'une sélection non avoué avec parfois
des tirages au sort et très souvent des
amphis bondés ou incapable d'accueillir
tous les étudiants rentrés dans des
bâtiments dont 40% sont dans un état de
dégradation inquiétante même franchement
préoccupante pour 12% d'entre eux je
cite le rapport de notre collègue anne
christine langues
mais on peut aussi consulter les deux
sites ma salle de cours va craquer ou
ruini d'université madame la ministre
faire évoluer l'enseignement supérieur
et les universités nécessaire
mutualisation des moyens des composantes
meilleur usage des nouvelles
technologies pédagogie inversée mais
cela nécessite aussi les réhabilitations
et adaptation des lieux d'enseignement
et de vie la réflexion sur les
conditions d'accès à l'université et
l'orientation l'anticipation de la
formation à de nouvelles pédagogies pour
les enseignants du supérieur comme du
secondaire pour les étudiants comme pour
les lycéens construire l'enseignement
supérieur du 21ème siècle ne peut être
une incantation un inventaire d'idées
une vaine promesse à la jeunesse sans
cesse renouvelé le budget de la mission
segment supérieur et recherche présentée
ce matin en commission élargie ne donne
aucun signe encourageant
alors madame la ministre quels axes
qu'elle réorientation des priorités et
des moyens et quel déploiement dans le
temps entendez vous retenir
je vous remercie merci
la parole est à mme secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la députée présidente mesdames
messieurs les parlementaires votre
question porte sur la rentrée
universitaire mais bien sûr bien au delà
la rentrée universitaire le nouveau
défis auxquels est confronté notre
université dont d'ailleurs il faut se
féliciter le succès de cette université
le nombre toujours plus grand des
étudiants qui veulent poursuivre des
études
le nombre toujours plus grand des
étrangers qui souhaitent faire leurs
études en france montre la capacité de
notre université a qualifié les jeunes
capacités reconnues d'ailleurs par l'
ocde puisque tous diplômés toutes
personnes diplômées de l'enseignement
succombe secondaire qui poursuit des
études dans l'enseignement supérieur en
france et diplômés à 80 % contre une
moyenne dans l'eau c d e qui est à 70%
mais vous avez raison ce ce bond
démographique on évalue aujourd'hui à 38
à 40 mille nouveaux étudiants hors
double compte pose un certain nombre de
défis le premier s'il défie de
l'immobilier ce défi le gouvernement y
répond puissamment dans les contrats de
plan état région
la led pour l'immobilier universitaire
des cinq années qui viennent est
équivalent à plus d'un milliard d'euros
complétée par un milliard d'euros par
les collectivités territoriales
le plan campus sur la prochaine période
là même 2015-2020 rajoutera 2,6
milliards d'euros à cet investissement
immobilier et donc au terme de ces
efforts nous aurons immobilier qui sera
de bien meilleure qualité peut-être que
des solutions innovantes devront
compléter cet effort par ailleurs sur le
plan budgétaire le budget qui a été
évoquée ce matin comme vous le dites en
commission mais qui a été adopté en
commission
marc un effort significatif le plus
important pour le programme de soutien
universités depuis le début du
quinquennat
puisque amendement gouvernemental
compris il sera porté à progression de
165 millions d'euros supplémentaires
enfin enfin grâce au numérique et grâce
à l'innovation pédagogique
notre université sera concilier la
démocratisation et l'exigence de qualité
qui doit animer les parcours de premier
cycle universitaire mai
si la parole est à madame france